you are watching cold face Channel hey
guys welcome to another cold fusion
video sorry about the delay ours meant
to actually do this Fox us run through
video a while back but I got busy with
some other stuff today I'm going to be
showing you foxes this is gonna be a bit
of a user guide it's just gonna show you
how to use some of the features and I'm
also going to show you some stuff that
we've got planned for the future alright
so let's start with this first page as
you can see at the top here you can
customize this top bar to say whatever
you like I'm just gonna put in potatoes
here just to give it a nice unique feel
so this first page is basically your
favorite apps so anytime you can go in
and edit and resize the icons to
whichever way you please as the slide
point sorry about the frame rate here
it's been captured at 15 frames per
second but the actual launcher runs a
lot smoother you know I put the screen
capture software in the highest quality
and it still kept at 15 frames per
second say so make do of what we've
gotten we'll just continue on so this
next page includes your essential
applications so all the applications
that you use most often and it's all put
into different folders and categories so
it's neat upon appearance but functional
upon execution so so literally you can
put whatever apps you want inside these
categories and have it pop out whenever
you need it
and you can rename the categories as
well which is also helpful on the third
page you can freely arrange and move the
different desktop icons as you wish and
what's interesting about this page has
actually got two different unique icon
setups for both portrait and landscape
so as you can see you can also move
around your date and text and these date
and texts widgets or clocks or whatever
you want to call them aren't exactly
just static these are actually live so
you can change these to one of the
different apps you want so I've got a
calendar on the bottom there and you can
put something such as a timer or a
timekeeping application on the top there
alright so let's move into the options
just for a second a few people have been
asking why the launch doesn't look as
advertised and doesn't have the 3d
flipping wallpaper effect and that's
because you need an application called
multi picture live wallpaper I didn't
get to show it to you in tutorial before
people actually purchased it but that's
assumed a lot of you were followers from
a while back so I I used to use that app
and I just thought most people would
know about it so that's the app that
gives that flipping effect moving on to
the widget pages literally a lot of
people are also asking you how to add
widgets and all you have to do is just
literally hold down the page and select
which was you you want and you would be
able to see that it's dynamic free
resizing which is not on many launches
if I'm not mistaken
not even any launches if I'm not
mistaken and you can add as many widgets
as you want however you want so you can
put them behind each other or on top of
each other or as close as you want next
to each other without any annoying grids
or anything
and also not unlike the icons there's
also different setups for landscape and
portrait orientation so the widgets can
be customized in that way as well so
let's take a look at some more options
you can go ahead and add another widgets
page if you want so that's basically
another blank page where you can put
whatever you want on your home screen
there's a whole bunch of stuff and voxer
settings so just some basics like
wallpaper scrolling the time format and
the extra folder at the top of the
second page of the UI you can actually
change that to behave as an app drawer
or folder or a settings menu for the top
bar there's different modes you can have
a transparent bar hide it all together
or just have a normal top bar a few
other options in there but there's
obviously going to be more added and
we'll get to that later and of course
one of the the big things about this is
you can change the font which will be
later Biafra scrollable list when this
is out of beta this this is kind of cool
because I don't think I've seen this on
many launches and obviously when I add
more fonts but it's just a way to give
that
will touch to your device without having
to route or do anything strange on the
left-hand side we have all your recent
apps so at any time you just swipe him
from the left and there was actually a
settings menu on there for the people
who did that didn't have software button
support but we've actually added that
now so that's all good
triple chapped access Google now of
course it works every time that's a very
handy feature I found wherever you are
in the launcher just to have Google now
available to you and you swipe up to get
to your app drawer at any time and yeah
I think that's about it so of course
that was just a quick look at boxes and
just what we have right now so just
please keep in mind this is the beta
version the open beta version and we've
got a lot of stuff planned some more
features coming which I'll get to in a
second but before that I do want to
touch on a light version of boxes so
this will mean it will be free in the
Play Store and before a lot of you start
throwing things at the computer screen I
will elaborate what's gonna happen with
this free version when Adam and I
released boxes last week I think we made
a little bit of an error releasing it as
a paid version because there are a lot
of people out there that actually wanted
to try out the products before actually
buying it which makes total sense and
now in hindsight we can totally see why
he would want to do that so what we're
gonna do is we're actually gonna make a
light version of boxes and this will
involve all the basic features of boxes
and obviously all the bugs fixed and
removed and this will be free from the
Play Store so you can just get a feel of
the launcher and obviously for the
people who have already paid and all the
future people they're gonna purchase the
pro version of boxes you guys will
obviously get all the new features and
updates as they come so let me just run
you through that quickly so you can just
see what Fox's aims to be ultimately
after it's out of open beta at the
moment so first off there's actually
already been an update with try to fix a
lot of the major crashes we've added
some soft key support the issue of the
phone dialer not showing up has been
resolved and there's been a few other
changes as well in the future we're
going to implement some custom boxes
screen layouts so this would mean that
you can choose from a variety of
pre-made screens just in case you want
to something a bit different you don't
want to work it out yourself and you can
just go ahead and select and choose how
you want we're also going to of course
include page transitions so this will be
the extra 3d effect on the
icons and the widgets we're gonna add
some more widget support to the other
pages and of course they're going to
provide some external icon pack support
and something else we're gonna add is a
pc mode so this would mean a layout that
is actually optimized for PC use so on
an external monitor or however you're
gonna use your phone in a PC environment
so this will actually involve a bar at
the bottom and in kind of windows style
interface so you'd use a mouse to click
over and you'd have an options menu that
kind of comes up from the left-hand side
and all that so working on that that's
all all in the works and later still
there's gonna be some multitasking
integration so multi window apps and
that kind of thing working natively from
Laxus so it gives you more functionality
and just different features from what
you'd normally expect from just a
launcher so that's that's where we're
going and anyway that was just to let
you know what's happening what we've
been working on and what's gonna be
happening in the future so we're working
to provide quick updates to you guys so
I've already got one update already and
there's gonna be a plenty more to come
so thank you for those of you who did
support and I'm also for the guys that
are were just curious and did check out
boxes thanks a lot for all your support
and also a hundred thousand subscribers
didn't even get a chance to talk about
that but yeah I'm just I'm just
speechless thanks a lot guys for your
support over the years and um it's been
it's been cool I think I will do a
proper video thanking you guys for that
but so anyway thanks for watching and as
usual don't forget to give a thumbs up
if you liked it comment and subscribe
and of course I'll catch you again soon
for the next video cheers guys
[Music]
you